so let me start with the big question
uh what do you think dennis from
observing report is doing right now
wow oh man
by the way that's my wife's favorite
character that i've done for some reason
by the way no no she's right but go on
of course um dude i wonder what he's
probably do
he's probably doing some like trying to
scam
uh you know on the computer he's got a
friend that knows
that's really good on the computer and
he's trying to like get some like
probably some credit card fraud or
something like that yeah
i could spend this whole interview
talking about observer and report and
how
great you were in that but let's jump
into tom and jerry when when you
do a project like tom and jerry how much
is tim
saying you have like freedom in the
moment to like sort of
improvise and have fun with the dialogue
and how much do you sort of feel
beholden
to what's on the page well what i do
with just about any project it doesn't
matter if it's like uh drama or
or you know comedy or you know any kind
of humor
like i i tend to like learn the dialogue
as
as as well as i can and
and really try to get that first and
then
um and i rehearse a lot so uh invariably
what'll happen is that i'll have ideas
that keep popping up in a certain area
um
while i earn a certain part of the scene
and then i just start writing those
those alts down um you know especially
like if
and i don't worry about like if if i'm
gonna forget him or not because
nine times out of ten if it's strong
enough in my opinion it'll just
just keep coming up so it's more like
there'll be
parts that i have alts and already
worked out and then i'll just try those
alts
and uh but because i found out early
i've actually found that in observatory
um you know we were we were joking
around a lot and
and it was my first comedy so i didn't
know
um really the rules of improving
and what you need to do is do everything
but do it in context
you know i would go off on tangents and
say a joke about like whatever was
happening on set
and then it would be in the cutting room
floor and uh and then i talked to the
director jody hill who i think is
awesome
and uh and you know he's like oh man it
was really funny man but it was like
it didn't quite move the story so that's
when i i i decided i was like oh okay
you really have to move the story along
listen i'm sure you grew up watching the
cartoons like everybody
how ridiculous is it being in a scene
with the two of them
you know what i mean like for example
towards the third act of the film you're
you know there's
a scene of you with tom scene of you
with jerry
talk a little bit about getting to do
that yeah i mean
i'm not gonna lie there's a couple times
where you where i look
i i just was aware of me and saying like
wow dude i'm a grown ass man
and i'm uh and i'm i'm i feel like a kid
right now
but at least i get paid for it right um
but what really helped us i'm like tim
was amazing man he really uh
you know created it and i know some
people say that sometimes but like
create an atmosphere
so that you can really um be in the
movie he hired puppeteers
and those puppeteers um were like
really like real puppeteers and they
were experts
um they were professionals and so when
we would do
a scene regardless if we were improving
or whatnot
um they would react and
appropriately and so like it would
inform the improv and it would
um and it would a lot of times like be
kept in the movie
and i never thought you know it was kind
of like a freebie in a way where like
even
there's a couple of times where i did
one of these and you know they used it
in a movie so
i thought it was awesome yeah i would
imagine you were trying to get them to
break
as puppeteers you know but anyway i
already got to go uh
listen i hope everything's going well
with you and your family and
nice to see you yeah dude take care
brother and i'll see you soon i'm sure